this is the Eastern Bongo these  beautiful chestnut and white striped  creatures can only be found in four  isolated regions of Kenya Eastern bongos  are fairly large in size and can weigh  anywhere from 500 to 900 pounds and  their horns can be as long as 40 inches  in fact their horns are wide as the  widest part of their body despite their  large size Eastern bongos are rather  timid creatures they are herbivores they  tend to eat and a most active during  Twilight and dusk as the darkness helps  them to hide from predators there is  estimated to be about a hundred bongos  left in the wild putting them well below  the critically endangered threshold  their biggest threats are hunting and  the destruction of their habitat in an  effort to protect the eastern bonger  various parts of their native habitat in  Kenya has been designated as shelters  for them allowing these to bonger to  move about freely and safely without  fear of perches this is the eastern  Bongo  [Music]